[Music]
so
hello everybody a very good morning it
is seven o'clock here in the united
kingdom you are very welcome to join us
for breakfast here on sky news wherever
you're watching us around the world
today we are at cop 26 again for day two
of the discussions here the world summit
120 leaders are here i'll start with
some good news for you this morning they
have struck a deal to stop destruction
of the world's forests within a decade
we'll have more on that also the queen
has been speaking directly to the
delegate she says i might not be here
but i'm keeping a wary eye on you lot in
addition to that we've got the
environment secretary on the program
this morning and indeed his labour
counterpart and once again we're taking
you right around the world
i'm in delhi as in day ignores the
international deadline to reach net zero
setting its target for 2017
here in the maldives there are plans to
turn an island of rubbish from an
environmental hazard into a sustainable
waste site
as they battle against climate change
that threatens their very way of life
china may be the biggest emitter of
greenhouse gases but president xi
jinping has said that developed nations
need to do more to support other
countries help prevent climate change
the campaign to suspend the rollout
atlas rollout of smart motorways that
use the hard shoulder as a live lane
and i'm live in jersey as france backs
down on its threat to ban british
vessels from french ports for now
[Music]
hello good morning to you it's being
held as a significant milestone to help
tackle the climate crisis news this
morning of an agreement by more than a
hundred countries including brazil and
also russia to stop and reverse
deforestation by 2030 but a warning to
leaders from the queen who told them
that they must uh
rise above the politics in hers words of
the moment to save the planet uh we'll
have more on that coming up in just a
few moments
time throughout today's show we're going
to be talking to our climate specialists
around the globe uh neville lazarus is
there in delhi for us after that shock
to uh 2070 target
from india tom cheshire is live in the
coal region of datong in china and also
ashish joshi is in the maldives which
could end up under water if temperatures
continue to rise
first though our main report from
rihanna mills on the deal to stop
deforestation and a message from the
queen
she is the only one who can deliver a
message like this the queen telling
other world leaders they must act now
and not for their own sakes of course
the benefits of such actions will not be
there to enjoy for all of us here today
we none of us will live forever
but we are doing this not for ourselves
but for our children and our children's
children
and those who will follow in their
footsteps there was an added poignancy
because of the recent worries about the
queen's health which meant her family
had to support the prime minister in
welcoming leaders to glasgow as the
monarch via video message asks them to
put their differences to one side
i for one hope that this conference will
be one of those rare occasions
where everyone will have the chance to
rise above the politics of the moment
and achieve true statesmanship
her message praising prince philip's
commitment to conservation and prince
charles and prince william's
environmental work came as her prime
minister prepared to announce the first
major deal of cop 26
with more than 100 leaders committing to
end deforestation by 2030
from canada and russia to colombia
indonesia and brazil a pledge which will
restore degraded land tackle wildfires
and support indigenous communities
backed by almost 14 billion pounds in
funding
forests absorb around one third of the
global co2 released from burning fossil
fuels every year but an area of forest
the size of 27 football pitches is lost
every minute brazil's greenhouse gas
emissions are increased in nine and a
half percent
last year during the pandemic which is
odd and brazil was one of the only
countries in the world that saw that uh
increased because the economy stopped
right during the pandemic and that was
due to deforestation
with some at cop 26 already not going
far enough on their climate commitments
the announcement on forests will at
least be seen as one positive as the
world leaders meet for another day
rhiannon mills sky news in glasgow
we're joined now from westminster by the
environment secretary george eustis mrs
thanks for joining us on the program
this morning why are you not here
well i will be there uh later um in this
week and there's a a day that's focused
on uh nature that's taking place on
saturday but uh we're we're kind of um
sharing the agenda between us over the
next couple of weeks and obviously the
prime minister has been opening the
event
are you flying up or coming by train i
will be coming by train
good to hear it um talk to me about this
new deal
well this is a really significant
breakthrough because we've now got over
100 countries covering around 85 of the
forests around the world committed to
ending the net loss of forests by 2030
and it includes key countries like
russia which has got a huge area forest
and obviously canada as well but also
some of the central african countries
responsible for the congo and brazil
which you know would surprise some
people but brazil has been really uh
actively engaged in this agenda and
underpinning that we've also
mobilized quite a lot of finance from
countries to support projects
to halt the the loss of forests and to
establish new forests and that's around
9 billion pounds of
commitments from governments and a
further 5 billion pounds from private
commitments
okay um you mentioned the brazilian
president of course he's not here um you
can take his word for it that he's going
to abide by these rules because of
course we found ourselves in this
position with him before and he's
reneged on the deal well they haven't
made any commitments like this before
and you know we work very hard with
brazil and with many other countries
over the last year to to get agreement
for this
i think things are starting to change in
brazil in terms of their approach and
look always
with these uh with these issues with
these multilateral agreements you've got
to work with countries you know we can
only deliver these changes if we can
carry countries uh you know like brazil
and unlike others around the world with
us it needs a whole world to come
together and make these commitments and
you've got to really work uh
constructively with countries like
brazil and with others and and that's
what we've been doing and i think it's
yielded some success the last big
attempt at doing something like this was
in 2014 with the uh the new york
declaration that only had about 40
countries and it didn't have any of the
major countries with forest so this is a
major step forward
okay oh the uh we've heard from the
indian government they uh are aiming for
net zero by 2070 is what they told us
last night that's not good enough is it
well obviously we we would um prefer it
if all countries committed to to do
net zero earlier we've committed to 2050
we would hope to but we should also you
know welcome this as a big step forward
uh india hadn't previously committed to
uh net zero uh they have got um um you
know more to do to to get there and you
know we should welcome what they've
committed to um even though we would
obviously always hope that people would
commit to do it earlier
but when people coming up with these
numbers they're almost telephone numbers
aren't they 20 70 who's around now that
will be able to hold them to task and
they're saying back in 2021 50 years ago
you told us that you'd be reaching these
targets and you haven't
well there'll be staging posts along the
way and so the other big focus of this
uh conference you'll hear a lot about
people talking about the the ndc's the
nationally determined contributions and
that is the commitments that each
country makes to reduce their carbon
emissions by 2030 and obviously in the
uk we've got a series of carbon budgets
another one in 2035
as staging posts towards net zero and
that's that applies to all countries so
while there's a long term target to get
to net zero there are many staging posts
between now and then and countries uh
around the world will be needing to take
policy decisions right now in order to
hit those uh staging posts and to
maintain their trajectory to net zero
okay so some hope for optimism we'll be
hearing uh from the uh president of
india and our prime minister within our
programme later on today but you know it
has to be said 2070 from india three of
the main
nations that we wanted here china russia
brazil are not here um we've heard from
the prime minister he's not particularly
optimistic we heard from your colleague
the foreign secretary yesterday she says
it's touch and go what what we'll get
out of cop 26 how confident are you as a
percentage that will get a deal
well look these uh events are always
complex uh you've got a multilateral
negotiations going on they will come up
with an agreement on the
the final day on the the 12th of
november and there's usually lots of
discussion that goes late into the night
but look what i would say is a week ago
i was i was apprehensive about the the
area i've been working on this this
product this um commitment on forests um
we didn't have it in the bag we weren't
sure whether countries would come
together but i think it's a really
encouraging sign that uh this early on
ahead of this forest event today
actually many of those countries have
come forward and said you know what
we're up for doing this uh and that's a
big breakthrough and i'm i'm delighted
with what we've achieved today on this
and you know if uh if this continues
then it will bode well for for the rest
of uh cop over the next couple of weeks
you're certainly much more confident
than your colleagues
well i think this is a an important
breakthrough had you spoken to me um you
know five days ago i also would have
been apprehensive about whether we would
have landed this agreement on forests
but we have and
you know it's looking really um
encouraging now today this is a big
breakthrough as i said not only have we
got countries responsible for 85 percent
of the world's forests committed to this
pledge
we've also got 28 uh countries that
are the big consumers of forest risk
products things like palm oil committed
to
more sustainability in supply chains and
crucially we've mobilized a lot of
finance to support this commitment so
this is a really significant
breakthrough
okay so um talking about deals the uh
french
what have we done there uh the papers
this morning saying la back down as far
as french fishing is concerned so this
is the brit have the brits won that
argument
well we welcome obviously the fact that
france has stepped back from the threats
that they were making last wednesday i
mean we had an agreement on fisheries
that we all concluded at the end of last
year we've been implementing that in
good faith there's
now around 1700
eu vessels that have been licensed to
fish in our waters around 750 of them
french there's a small number of vessels
around 55 that wanted access to jersey
waters but haven't yet been able to
demonstrate that they
that they previously accessed that
during what's called the reference
period
we've always been clear that we're open
to further dialogue on that um and that
if there's new evidence that can be
brought to bear then obviously we would
consider that we want to license any
vessel that qualifies under the terms of
the agreement we reached a year ago
but obviously we really welcome the fact
that france has stepped back from what
they threatened and there's going to be
further discussions on thursday
so it's a back down by the french
well look um it's a decision by the
french to step back from the threats
that they made last wednesday we welcome
that uh we know for our part though um
we've always said we want to de-escalate
this and we've always said that we have
an ever open door to
discuss any further evidence that france
or the eu might have on any additional
vessels they'd like to have licensed
so you're confident that fishing wars
has gone away now
well it has in the sense that um france
has clearly been
taken a decision not to
implement some of the measures that they
threatened last wednesday we very much
welcome that uh but i think there's
gonna be a really important meeting on
thursday uh between lord frost and uh
and his opposite number not just on
fisheries but on a wider range of issues
as well you know it's really it's really
important for us to have good relations
with our nearest neighbor and a close
ally uh and so we welcome the decision
that the french have taken
uh and that uh impounded uh fishing
vessel that's been returned has it uh
yes i understand um that that vessel has
now been released um i i think there may
uh there's gonna be need to be some
further discussions there clearly was a
administrative error at some point we
haven't quite got to the to the bottom
of that but uh but yes that uh that
vessel i understand has been released
okay good news for the skipper and the
crew um
well well i've got you um we're talking
about uh cop and also i wanted to bring
in brexit if i may because a couple of
months ago maybe only six weeks ago you
were on the show and you said that uh
president biden didn't understand the
full complexities of the northern
ireland uh protocol
he's here at the summit what's your
message to him today do you think he
understands it a little better now
well look um the the the point that i
was making is that um in the context of
the northern ireland protocol
nobody believes in the good friday
agreement more than the uk government
where a signatory to it we absolutely
stand behind
peace in northern ireland and all the
provisions of that agreement but part of
the good friday agreement also
require you to
be um recognizing the importance of uh
northern ireland being in the uk and
that sort of what's called the east-west
uh dimension to it as well that was the
um the point that i was making
and that is why you know lord frost is
also
trying to
basically have a discussion with the
european union about how we should
approach and implement the northern
ireland protocol so that it works in a
way that's consistent with the good
friday agreement
so which bit of the northern ireland
protocol did you think the president
didn't understand
um i think um
from memory it was um i think you put it
to me that um the united states felt
that by the changes we were proposing
were somehow
at odds with the good friday agreement
which is simply untrue they were
they were entirely um actually uh
consistent with a good friday agreement
and in fact the reason we need to try to
change the way we approach the northern
ireland protocol
is that as it's being currently
interpreted it's not really working for
the good friday agreement
uh okay so it was me that was
misunderstanding as opposed to the
president
well i think
you were pushing to me kay if i recall
um
reports in the press about what the u.s
administration might have thought
okay i'm not going to okay um
okay as far as president biden is
concerned you think that he does
understand the northern ireland protocol
you think that he's on board as far as
brexit is concerned and despite him
saying over the weekend that his closest
uh allies in europe are the french we
can still do business with him and
although we haven't got any deals with
the americans as yet as far as uh trade
is concerned that's very much on the
agenda while the two leaders are here
well look i've not spoken to president
biden about the good friday agreement so
um uh you know it's this is um something
obviously that i'm sure the prime
minister does as well as talk to him
about what we're trying to achieve with
the northern ireland protocol so that it
is consistent with the good friday uh
agreement i'm not even sure if that's on
the agenda obviously this week
everybody's very very much focused on
getting the right kind of agreement on
climate change the u.s has
substantially increased its commitment
to international climate finance
and it's also been a really important
ally on some of the work we're doing not
just on forests but also on oceans as
well so we really welcome the role that
they're playing at this conference
okay just before i let you go obviously
it's a green conference here we're doing
our best to try and cut
fossil fuel emissions
what are the big things that you do at
home to try to save the planet
well um look like everybody i've tried
to pay attention to the um dividing of
waste and making sure that we recycle as
much as possible
as i said earlier i'm going to be going
to uh cop by uh by train and um whenever
i travel to the constituency i generally
do so by train um there's all uh you
know all of us have got things that we
uh can do but crucially in order to hit
these uh targets there's going to be a
big role for
technology new technologies coming
forward that are more sustainable that
do wean us off our dependence on fossil
fuels
and getting those technologies deployed
is going to be the single most important
thing we can do
have you got an electric vehicle
i don't have an electric vehicle i've
got a mini a small mini that's got a
green mode on it um but i don't yet have
an electric vehicle but obviously
after around 2030 we're saying that all
new vehicles should be uh electric
and
soon thereafter of course um
people still be able to buy petrol and
diesel vehicles second hand
but we are on a trajectory to phase
those out over the next 10 years to 20
years
and have you got a heat pump
i know i don't have um a heat pump at
the moment um but it's certainly um
something that
i would look at obviously we're trying
to encourage all of these technologies
but look as i mentioned i'm the same as
as many other people that um we all want
to to do the right thing and make these
changes we need the technology to uh
come forward we need to
set a trajectory um there are everybody
wants to make these changes sometimes
the technology is not quite there yet
but we are making progress in the right
direction
good to talk to you hopefully we'll see
you later on in the week thanks very
much thank you very much
thanks a lot and just a reminder
if you want to catch up on any of that
interview or indeed
you can watch it if you would like to
the rest of the program when you're out
and about this morning you can find us
on the mobile app or go to our website
and go into our live blog to watch the
programme live and you can catch up as
well on the interviews on my twitter
that's at k burley
now throughout today's show we are going
to be talking to our climate specialists
around the globe for you and neville
lazarus is in delhi after that shock 27
target from india tom cheshire is live
in the coal region of da tong in china
and ashish joshi is in the maldives
which could end up under water if
temperatures continue to rise
let's go first this morning to ashish
joshi in the maldives hello to you
ashish what's the latest from the
maldives today
well it's a recognition from the
moldivian government that it needs to do
as much as it can to protect its own
nation we visited an island of waste a
notorious
island of waste that has been smoldering
and smoking and burning for 30 years
belching toxic fumes
into the atmosphere and if you think
about the archipelago and you think
about the geography where does an island
of hundreds and hundreds of atolls throw
its waste it can't throw it into the
ocean there are 400 000 people who call
the maldives their home and up to a
million tourists a year all bringing
with them their own rubbish what used to
happen kay is all of this rubbish was
collected and dumped on an island known
as thilafushi known to locals as trash
island but now they recognize that
burning all of this waste it wasn't even
sorted so all of this waste collected
together set on fire and that fire raged
for 30 years it's only just been
extinguished because the moldivian
government recognizing that it has to
contribute as much as it can towards
protecting its own environment and now
what they'll do is they'll transform
this island into a sustainable green
energy plant taking all of that waste
and having a closed incinerator burning
that waste to produce green energy which
can be used in the islands but there is
also a recognition that whatever they do
here
is interdependent on what the rest of
the world does so there is a delegation
from the maldives which has traveled to
cop26 they spoke to me before they left
they say we only have the one voice
we'll do everything we can to make sure
it's heard
never lazarus is in delhi for us this
morning neville good morning
morning k
well we've we've uh we've had some a lot
of news about
india setting its target for 2017 of net
zero there's a bit of tear out here from
government organization but a lot of
skepticism from climate activists and
scientists
how india was going to reach those that
target is is is going to be a an uphill
task because india relies a lot on coal
over 70 percent of india's grid is is
powered by coal more than 50 percent of
the gdp is solely uh comes from fossil
fuel and and cold uh
coal energy and and this is going to be
an uphill task for india to balance that
economic development and also climate
change though india has set itself
for a 2017
net zero
according to sky news data teams in
recent years the country has become the
world's
largest emitter of sulfur dioxide which
has been linked to millions of deaths
this graphic from nasa shows that while
china's sulphur dioxide emissions have
fallen india has has sharply risen
sulphur dioxide contributes to air
pollution which causes acid rain and
environmental damage now india is on the
front line of climate change over the
last few years we have seen an increase
in cyclones
flooding
heat waves and droughts and the
intensity
rising even more than the previous years
affecting the lives and livelihoods of
millions of people and india will have
to make that fine balance between
economic development and climate change
okay okay thanks very much let's bring
in tom cheshire should we he's in shanxi
province in china for us this morning
tom we've been talking a lot about the
fact that the chinese president is
not here tell us the latest from china
this morning
yeah he's certainly not a copy still
here in china what he did do yesterday
was submit basically a note it wasn't
even a video address uploaded to the
website published on the website putting
forward china's point of view what
they've been doing over the last year is
really battening down the hatches in
every sort of geopolitical field it
feels the same way with climate change
we got no new climate pledges before cop
uh we were hoping for some we're
certainly not expecting any in his note
and we didn't get any of them instead
it was looking at developed countries to
try and help other nations uh china
classes itself as a developing nation
and saying that what's more important
than words is deeds and that might be
again uh rather sort of
and say you don't even have to be a cop
it's about what you do at home that's
important and that is the case to some
extent um even though there have been no
new pledges from china what we have seen
is at least a doubling down on the
commitments that's already made last
year
trying to entrench it in the bureaucracy
trying to turn around a juggernaut
economy that's been built on dirty
growth but it isn't an easy transition
to make i'm here in datong as you
mentioned this is coal country but i'm
actually in the old town right now
they're trying to redevelop it turn it
into a tourist attraction but they can't
really get away from coal for now just a
few hours driving here there are lots of
coal plants still being put up we
visited three in between them they
represent more than the entire coal
output of the uk those are under
construction and that's not china
slipping on his goals those are the
goals china has pledged to build more
coal power until 2025 so that might seem
all fairly depressing but i think there
is still some hope for cop26 even
without xi jinping being there his uh
climate envoy xi jinhua
is empowered to sort of talk to people
it might even be easier because there's
not the sense of losing face to
foreigners and then other countries
could perhaps put china when it comes to
reducing coal emissions to do it more
quickly than they promised but it won't
be xi jinping in the room himself making
those commitments
okay um tom in china neville in india
and also ashish in the maldives thank
you all very much for the updates uh we
are live in glasgow at cop 26 with day
two of the summit a lot more hope this
morning from the environment secretary
um ashna's here what do you think i
thought him saying that he was
apprehensive at first maybe a few days
ago ahead of that announcement when it
comes to deforestation and
you know looking at um
encouraging more of those rainforests to
flourish i suppose they are described as
the lungs of the planet um taking up and
soaking up tons of carbon
but him now saying that he described
this as a being a big breakthrough um
the uk government has pledged some 1.5
billion pounds and globally they've
agreed to some 19 billion pounds being
pumped into rainforest and that's going
to be beneficial to places to
rainforests like brazil at amazon where
mark austin is but also indonesia
and canada too in norway and so lots of
these countries are going to be
benefiting from this huge amount of
money but that is a pledge of course
they're wanting us to focus on but still
we've got those reminders of yesterday
we were hoping for that big breakthrough
from india we got it in some form but
2070 is a long long time i mean five
decades away from from now i'll be 60 by
then
it's a long long time it's a long time
away
we're going to hear from the indian
prime minister later on aren't we we are
um it will be interesting to hear from
him whether there is any movement on
that i think it's probably likely that
in his meeting yesterday with the prime
minister he probably you know was hoping
for that big headline stealing moment
you know come on now
boris saying probably come on now modi
let's see if we can get you to be on the
front pages but they're suddenly on the
front pages for not all the right
reasons 2017 is such a long time away
but we have to remember they are a
developing nation and they're not going
to be able to switch to a green economy
or with that green infrastructure as
quickly as some of those other
developing nations this is a country
with a huge amount of poverty um so then
even saying they've got some form of a
target is good but they have made that a
carbon emission target in 2030 so that
is positive okay thank you for being
kind about my age um we'll see you in
about half an hour or so thanks very
much indeed
thank you here's a look at climate
change as it is happening
you can see on
the
dashboard that we've got here we go the
estimated temperature change compared to
pre-industrial levels this is now above
1.2 degrees under that is the estimated
total carbon dioxide emissions most of
this comes we're told from burning
fossil fuels and continues to rise
feeding that temperature change
and then you can see on the right the
real-time power mix this data comes from
the national grid and illustrates the
sources of our electricity you can't see
that just at the moment um
a slight glitch on our screen we'll sort
that out for you and of course we'll
update it a little bit later on in the
programme
and as world leaders gather at cop 26 we
take a look at the impacts climate
change is having right around the world
that's in a special programme on sky
news tonight at 7 pm
still to come on the program for you the
chinese president talking a lot about
him haven't we over the last few days he
isn't coming to glasgow half past seven
we'll try and find out what he is doing
at home to prevent climate change
[Music]
what is manchester doing to prevent
climate change we'll be joined by the
city's mayor that's andy burnham of
course he's joining us at a quarter to
eight
and then after eight o'clock we'll ask
the shadow environment secretary luke
pollard
talking to him in more detail about
whether labour believes the government
will get a global agreement after the
first day of the glasgow summit
there are calls to suspend the rollout
to smart motorways which
use the hard shoulder as live lanes
because of safety concerns talking about
that in more detail with katie barnfield
she is by the m1 forward this morning
near bletchley hello to you katie tell
us more about this story
well good morning kay yes as you say the
transport committee have now called for
the building of all new smart motorways
to be suspended
until safety concerns are addressed and
they say the problem is there is simply
not enough data yet not enough safety
data to prove that they are safe and
therefore justify continuing with the
project now as you say they have what
they have a particular problem with is a
type of smart motorway called all lane
running motorways now the government has
committed to make all new smart
motorways this type of motorway which
use the hard shoulder as a live lane at
all times but there are concerns over
safety because of the number of fatal
accidents that have happened where a car
has been stopped in a live lane and
another car has come along behind it and
crashed into it now the committee say
they want safety measures to be
introduced that they asked for
five years ago already things like more
refuge areas for broken down cars on
this type of motorway and also an
independent commission to be introduced
to review the safety of smart motorways
before going forward now the government
has responded this morning they say they
are going to look at the recommendations
of the transport committee in a lot of
detail
okay thank you casey we're going to
discuss that report with claire mercer
who founded the smart motorways kill
campaign after a husband was killed in a
smart motorway accident that's after
eight o'clock this morning
before that though let's talk about
france they appear to have stepped back
for now from the threat to ban british
vessels fishing vessels from french
ports
and other vessels as well of course the
environment secretary telling us just
now he welcomes the fact that the french
have backed down
i'm not remotely happy about what has
happened as you can as you can hear me
say
i want to see this situation resolved
these these threats are
unwarranted and they're not the actions
we would expect of a friend and ally of
the united kingdom
becky johnson joining us now on jersey
this morning hello to you becky so the
worst concerns from the government
ministers on jersey yesterday um what
are they saying this morning
yeah good morning kay well relief uh
here in jersey we're out here in the
harbour fisherman mark taking us out
this morning and the fishing communities
here in jersey and in the uk
have have had something of a reprieve
really with this uh the threat of french
ports being closed to them delayed as
talks continued there had been fears
among these fisher communities that
those ports were closed to fishermen
from jersey and the uk
from midnight last night but then
president macron said that he felt talks
should continue so talks between the two
sides are continuing today uh the
delay by president macron in imposing
what he'd threatened which also included
more checks on lorries coming in from
the uk to france that has been welcomed
by the uk government the decision to
continue talking rather than uh imposing
those uh extra checks and blocking ports
and we understand brexit minister lord
frost is going to be uh talking with
french officials on thursday about a
number of brexit issues so uh
potentially no action until at the
earliest after those talks so the threat
of the closure of french ports of course
for the fishermen here in jersey the
vast majority of their fish is sold in
europe and goes in via france so that
would be a huge blow and potentially
threaten the livelihoods of the
fishermen here
that that threat has been delayed but it
hasn't yet gone away of course all of
this began when in september the uk and
jersey didn't give permits to a number
of french fishermen to fish in waters
around here so it's whether uh which
side is going to back down really and
that's what the fishermen here uh are
thinking mark just a quick word from you
how are people feeling today do you feel
the threats gone away
um i don't think it's not gonna go away
until one of them back down
yeah
and that that's what people are saying
they think it's really going to be who
blinks first is it going to be the uk is
it going to be france but for now as i
say a reprieve as we head out on this
beautiful morning
for a bit of fishing
looks a bit choppy though where you are
becky how is it
not half as choppy as it was yesterday
okay when we were out on the water in
fact it's been
really windy for the last few days and
the fishermen haven't been able to
properly go out for the last few days so
a lot calmer than it was yesterday
that's for sure okay lovely thank you
thanks a lot
uh well the environment secretary we've
been talking to him this morning he says
that he is hopeful of a final deal on
greenhouse gas emissions and that they
can be agreed at the cop 26 summit here
in glasgow this morning there's an
agreement by more than 100 different
countries including brazil and russia to
stop and reverse deforestation by 2030.
earlier george eustis told us he was
increasingly optimistic an agreement
would be reached
a week ago i was i was apprehensive
about the the area i've been working on
this this product this commitment on
forests
we didn't have it in the bag we weren't
sure whether countries would come
together but i think it's a really
encouraging sign that this early on
ahead of this forest event today
actually many of those countries have
come forward and said you know what
we're up for doing this
and that's a big breakthrough and i'm
i'm delighted with what we've achieved
today on this
tomorrow's with us hi tomorrow i'm sorry
pretty optimistic
hi kay yes today is the last day the
world leaders will be there and i think
boris johnson will be very much
trumpeting this achievement a hundred
countries at the summit have signed up
to a pledge to halt and reverse
deforestation by 2030 now the last time
countries signed up to this in 2014 at a
previous climate summit you only got 40
countries and they didn't include brazil
or china which have a lot of the world's
forest so this is the government feel a
very significant achievement george
eustis called it an important
breakthrough that all these countries
had signed up to it and it will they say
make a real difference to cutting carbon
emissions because here's a staggering
statistic for you the equivalent of 27
football pitches of forest is lost every
single minute at the moment and the
speed of the deforestation of the amazon
in brazil is really escalating all the
time so this is going to be crucial so
as well as the bigger deal to cut carbon
emissions these side deals on coal and
on forests and on electric cars are
really where the british government is
looking to make significant progress so
they'll be really pleased with this
today but look it's not legally binding
and the monitoring of it is going to be
crucial because of course a lot of
people make their living out of logging
forests and how this is going to be
overseen is obviously a big question but
diplomatically it is an achievement that
the british government will be really
pleased with on this this key important
day of the conference when world leaders
are all there they're all going to be
going home tonight so that the whole
process of negotiating can begin in
earnest tomorrow
okay thank you
now tens of thousands of people are here
in glasgow four cop 26 but the biggest
and uh perhaps most important person
some might say isn't in town that is
president uh president xi jinping
he has stayed at home so how is he doing
at home to tackle the crime the climate
change what is he doing at home to
tackle the climate crisis joining us is
dr zizi who honorary research associate
at the university of oxford um joining
us as i said live hello to thanks for
joining us um
is president of china making any real
difference at home in china even though
he isn't here today
hi okay um
thank you very much for having me um
yeah so i think uh while you know uh
appearing at cop uh um is an important
political statement um let's take a step
back and think about the science of it
and which is all about the commitments
and the delivery of those commitments so
at home um
china is pledging um a carbon peak by
2030 which basically means that
emissions will peak um by 2030 and it is
pledging uh carbon neutrality by 2060
which means um carbon emissions that are
emitted into the atmosphere will be
balanced by emissions savings elsewhere
um so it is really about these um
commitments that are going are being
made um right now
not been much changed since 2015 has
there do you think we'll see significant
changes from china in the next decade
um you know the climate science
community obviously um hopes that there
will be uh you know significant um
changes um and i think the the issue
right now is that unfortunately um china
does face a lot of um challenges in in
when it comes to green transition and
that's that's not unique to china it's
also you know a challenge for other
countries um but yeah we do we do we do
know that the emissions reductions will
need to happen um we need to take this
very seriously and it's you know um an
effort that the country
will need to make
okay we are hearing that china are
planning next zero is it by 2060
that's a very long way away i mean it's
better than india 2070 but goodness me
um do we have that much time
um
you know again this this is um an issue
that highlights how important and what a
challenge that the country faces right
um so but i i do think that um
um the country will make um significant
progress um on this issue but we'll have
to see what happens um but one of the
things that i would like to highlight is
that emissions reductions are extremely
you know important um but that's not
only half of the story or half of the
battle because the other half of the
battle is really about adaptation which
we don't seem to talk about that much um
it is about understanding how do we
build our society our economy and you
know our infrastructure systems to a
resilient standard that they can
withstand um climate extremes um and
that is unfortunately because we have
locked ourselves in to a development
path that actually you know from his
historical emissions even if we produce
stop producing everything now there are
climate impacts that are gonna happen
and um we don't talk you know enough i
think about this issue of adaptation so
you know like um how do we design
hospitals or how do we design road
networks or power networks you know if a
flood event hits um
do they have you know backup generators
do they have you know protective
measures in place so that we can you
know make sure that they still function
um that is unfortunately um
not talked or discussed enough i think
and what about the
people of china um how
do they react to climate change are they
on board are they engaged from your
experience
from all my own experience it's been
phenomenal right i think um
you know if i talk about my family or
friends the um the issue of climate
change wasn't really a thing i would say
10 years ago but now
it is a very very much like an engaged
debate if you watch the news on in china
i haven't personally been back in two
years but i i you know i hear from my
parents my cousins and family members
they tell me oh my gosh you know
you study climate change and we have
floods and we have you know a lot of air
pollution what are we going to do i i do
think there is a huge movement now in
china um in terms of the people's
engagement and kind of literacy or
understanding of climate issues and it's
definitely on people's minds
okay it's good to talk to you and thanks
for staying up for us in boston united
states of america this morning we very
much appreciate it off to bed thank you
thank you so much bye thank you bye-bye
with us now is the mayor of manchester
andy burnham hiya hi kate um cop 26 is
gonna be a success uh it's hard to say i
think
i felt it was a bit nervy a bit jittery
uh yesterday so it's it's in the balance
i i would say
uh from from my point of view we're
ready to go in greater manchester we've
got a plan to really move towards a zero
carbon great monster by 2038 but we're
not yet getting the full buy-in and
backing uh that we need to get there so
you know it is doable it's tough but
doable uh we just need that that full
government partnership uh to get there
you mean money i do and you know i'm not
just coming on to make cheap political
points there was money for us in the
budget uh for public transport
investment a billion pounds which was
great but we don't yet have the money to
decarbonize the bus fleet so we're
bidding for money for bus improvement
and we don't yet have that money and you
know the big thing i want to get over is
you know until
we do something on fairs for public
transport we're not going to be in the
right place when it's cheaper to catch a
plane than it is to catch a train or
it's cheaper for a couple of young
people to get a taxi than it is to get a
bus as it is in greater manchester we're
just not going to be in the right place
so i would have much preferred to see
the government saying right we're going
to bring down rail fares we're going to
bring down bus fares rather than
lowering airfares in the recent budget
what if you don't get the money
well we won't be able to hit 2038 so
what i've said to the government is if
you back us not just on public transport
but on
retrofitting people's homes to make them
zero carbon we can remove a million tons
of carbon from the greater manchester
economy by 2025 and i can do that the
reason i can say that in the way that
other mayors can't is because i've taken
the decision to put buses back under
public control after 35 years of
deregulation so finally we will decide
what buses are on our roads not the bus
operators and for that reason i can give
them a guarantee that i can remove
carbon from the great monster economy
but they do need to back me to do it
professor kevin anderson says greater
manchester is currently
falling short of its commitments um
that's uh he is uh
a tundra center professor on climate
change um so what do you agree with him
and what you're going to do to try and
fix it well yes i don't think anyone is
is doing enough uh to be honest kay and
the thing is
you know this cop there's a danger of it
looking like lots of
entitled wealthy people have come to
lecture everybody about they have about
their lives and and i can see that and i
can i can feel uh feel that i think
that's what a lot of people feel who are
watching i know it either they think you
know posh people telling us what we
should do and i can't afford to feed the
kids i know i mean you and i know what
people in wigan will be will be thinking
about about about this and i think the
story is going to be turned round at
this cop because to be honest with you
this is the route to a lower cost of
living
for for people so if i get my way in
greater manchester one pound 50 a bus
journey like it is in london that will
help a lot of people and actually would
be a real reason for them to leave the
car at home if we retrofit people's
homes their energy bills can come right
down and become more stable
well that's where the government has to
come in you know we won't get there
without upfront costs but the thing is
you can reduce the lifetime costs
by putting in that upfront investment so
if you invest in an electric car
it's cheaper to run than a petrol or a
diesel car so therefore the money is
saved over the lifetime of that over
that that vehicle so the government has
to put in that upfront investment but
then it will be setting us up to
hopefully reduce the cost of living for
people and i don't think that that
message is getting over at the moment
the drive to net zero could be the way
to level up the country it could be the
route to better public transport better
homes for people
jobs for people doing all of that all of
that work on people's homes but i i
still feel we haven't quite as a country
got got our kind of message lined up
properly on this you mentioned evs
electric vehicles i've learned to call
them ev's while i've been here um
there's nowhere to plug them in
yeah well i mean the infrastructure i
don't know what it's like in greater
manchester one of our colleagues thomas
more went from paris to glasgow he was
struggling to find places to charge the
car yeah well i mean it's not good
enough and you quoted professor anderson
and rightly you know we i need to be
challenged and we're not yet doing
enough anything so what's it like in
great manchester uh we have a number and
we have uh got a new partnership with an
ev when you say a number like as a
percentage how many
fewer is it than you know we've got uh
we've got about 300 at the moment but
there's another 100 going in this year
another 200 going in next year so we're
expanding them well i think it depends
on how quickly people change their
vehicles doesn't it so we have we don't
have enough and you need the really
rapid charging points because taxi
drivers can't be hanging around all day
waiting for
of us can none of us can so you know yes
this all needs changing we've got a bike
hire scheme that's launching this month
um we are doing quite a lot but we are
the we are unique because we're putting
putting buses under public control we
are uniquely placed to create the
country's first net zero public
transport system why k because our trams
in greater manchester the biggest tram
system in the uk one of the biggest in
europe already runs on renewable energy
and that's a great story for us to be
able to come here and
and shout about but imagine if the buses
were electrified as well they were
running on renewable energy it was all
one system where it was one pound 50 a
journey that i think is when you're
really getting in the game of helping
people
helping people buy into this journey
towards net zero because as you rightly
said before i think some of the public
might be hearing some of this and
watching some of this and starting to
switch off a little bit
do you to paraphrase one of your former
leaders do you feel the weight of
history on your shoulder given that the
northwest was the home of the industrial
revolution and a lot of this carbon
emission now is as a direct result of
what we were doing in the 1880s oh you
can't help but look back at the history
of greater manchester and
look at that first industrial revolution
and we did lead it we led it as a region
we led it as a country
and obviously we've de-industrialized uh
since since then and i think this is the
opportunity that's staring us now right
in the face the drive to net zero could
reindustrialize the north of england but
this time in a good way where it's it's
clean and we give people clean air to
breathe that's that's an opportunity
that we've got as a country you've got
steve rotherham in liverpool the mayor
talking about a tidal barrier to heat
all the homes in the liverpool city
region we've got a green hydrogen
cluster in in trafford what does that
mean
it's well it's the cleanest form of
hydrogen and it'll be a big energy
source in the future it's coming through
now as a new technology wind up in the
northeast the north of england could
lead the next industrial revolution it
needs the government to back it we've
had a lot of rhetoric about them saying
we believe in the north we're backing
the north the mayors aren't yet feeling
it properly to be honest with you and
that window to do something is kind of
closing i'm not letting you off without
telling me what you think about ikea
styles leadership at the moment
well i i thought the party did a very
good response uh to the budget last week
i say the party because kier obviously
is isolating at the moment but i thought
rachel reeves shadow chancellor in
difficult circumstance did a terrific
job you know that first line that she
said that they've prioritized bankers
sipping champagne on internal flights i
mean that kind of nailed it really and
that that's opposition that this
government needs i mean you know that
budget if you think about it and you
look at what's happening here this week
it's completely out of kilter
with with this event and i think
labour the front bench nailed that last
last week and i think kia had a had a
good conference
i know unfortunate that he wasn't able
to respond to to the budget but labour's
got an opportunity on all the points
that i was saying before big promises
have been made to the north of england
polls are terrible still i mean that the
prime minister's had a mayor over the
last month and they're still leading in
the polls
well that's why i think they need to
obviously they need a new leader well
we've had a pandemic effect haven't we
where you know there's been this cross
party and national unity but now is the
chance to get after a government that i
think is is failing on its promises
there's a big thing coming uh which is
around rail investment in the north and
labour
from the top needs to hold the
government to account for us as northern
leaders because we here they're about to
break a lot of their rail investment
promises to the north of england well
we'll see won't we but these are the
opportunities that labour needs to seize
now and hold the government to account
you're answering like a politician in
other words you're not answering the
question well the polls aren't great but
the question being that labour needs to
do to do more well definitely i would i
would does he need a new leader no it
doesn't no it doesn't it's got a really
strong leader in kierstarma uh but how
long does he have to prove himself well
i don't think there is a you never put a
time frame on these on these things i
think he needs to be given the support
now the party did get behind him at the
recent conference that was clear it
responded well to his speech it received
it well uh and now is the chance to to
really go into opposition proper because
we've not really had that for the last
couple of years and and if the polls
have to move let's be honest about that
though the polls really need to to move
back in labour's in labour's favor but i
think there's an opportunity here and
what do you want to achieve while you're
here
we want to be the uk's leading green
city region we're already the uk's
leading digital city region but i want
greater manchester to lead that next
industrial revolution but the message
i'm getting over here trying to is let's
have climate justice and social justice
together so let's close these gaps in
society give people cheaper public
transport that's much better better
homes create jobs for young people in
doing all of that that work narrow some
of these divides in society i think you
can level up with the drive to net zero
and you know that's my big message
greater manchester is ready to go to do
all of those things just before i let
you go uh the c word kovid
where are we in greater manchester
confident that you won't have another
lockdown uh well we certainly wouldn't
accept any form of local or regional uh
regional lockdown the cases have been
high they've fallen a little uh they
were they were higher about two weeks
ago but still you know in
mid 600 per 100 000 there's a high level
of cases and a number of our boroughs
but the hospitalization is not the same
you know it's not feeding through into
high levels of hospital hospitalization
they're kind of stable those figures at
the moment so we've got a very close
watch on it i'll say it again i'm sure
some of your viewers won't like it i
just believe we should be wearing masks
on public transport not everywhere but
on publication
where i control the system which is
metrolink i have said uh it's a
requirement uh and now obviously with
people not required to wear them
elsewhere it's hard to maintain that but
i would take the government come on back
us up on this you know we've got a
difficult winter ahead of us and the
thing is kay you mentioned what about
covid well it's not just going to be
covered is it's going to be flu it's
going to be all those seasonal viruses
flu have you had your jobs no well i've
had my double jab but i'm waiting for
the booster which i've talked six years
after not yet no but i'm gonna have that
at the same time okay say you're
lecturing people and you've not talked
about
people i was talking about masks and i
do wear my mask on on public transport
but um you know i'm not trying to i'm
not trying to lecture anybody i'm just
saying we're in a difficult place aren't
we as a country we're not out of the
pandemic i know
people have been given the impression
that we are but we're not
i just think we need to look at what's
coming now we're in now the clocks have
gone back and winter's here and just be
sensible where we need to be and and
avoid a lockdown because that was your
first question we don't want to be back
there do we this this year okay it's
good to talk to you thanks for giving us
so much of your time no problem
thanks so much indeed thanks a lot the
mayor of greater manchester andy burnham
talking to us about a whole range of
things here at cop 26 wants to lead the
country with the next industrial
revolution and that's a green revolution
is what he was saying but he can't do it
without uh direct funding from the
government uh coming up in the next hour
we're going to be speaking uh to the
shadow environment secretary about the
new rules that hopefully the british
government have put in place as far as
deforestation is concerned cutting that
back in the next decade to improve
this
planet i love this it's such a fantastic
image isn't it there you go hovering
above us here at cop 26 the blue zone
continuing coverage on sky
[Music]